hallo liebe Kinder ich bin der Nikolaus
und auch dieses Jahr mache ich meinen
lieblingspolitikerinnen und Politikern
schöne Geschenke in die Latschen dem
Christian Linder fen gerade 60
Milliarden Euro ist doch kein Problem
der Olaf kriegt von mir eine
Zimmerpflanze damit im Gegensatz zu
seinen umfragenwerden auch mal was
wächst für Klimaschutz gibt's jetzt kein
Geld mehr deswegen kann der Robert jetzt
einfach selber pusten Friedrich hat
Angst dass Ausländer uns die Zähne
wegnehmen deswegen für ihn gr für den
Bern höcke ein Erlebnisgutschein für
eine
Abschiebung für die Sara ein
apfelspalter weil sie sich so gern
abspaltet hier kann sie richtig ein
wegspalten für den Markus gibt's wie
immer Wurst aber Vorsicht ist Bio froh
Nikolaus und frohes Fest